hello everyone and welcome back to
rotten tomatoes is wrong it's your girl
jaclyn and i'm back with my beloved
co-host mr mark ellis how you doing mark
beloved wow this is uh this is an
upgrade i will tell everybody that i got
a very special invitation i cannot say
what it's pertaining to but it's an
exclusive guest list that jaclyn hooked
me up with so oh
yes very excited about that
there may be instagram photos that some
of you may see soon of me and mark out
in the wild that's all i will say yeah
we're gonna make everybody peanut butter
and
jelly especially
uh but of course we're back again with
another episode and this time this is a
highly highly requested highly talked
about i feel like every like six months
on twitter people are like going off
about how much they love this film and
shout out to lizzy from guadalajara she
is one of mark's followers on twitter
and she has been begging for us to cover
a brendan fraser film this is the
episode this is the time because we are
talking about the 1999 classic the mummy
which is currently rated at 61 fresh on
the tomato meter but has a 75 audience
score so
let's just talk about it brendan fraser
who mark did you read like his like gq
have you been following this like
resurgence i was gonna do a deep dive
into brennan fraser last night and i got
swept away watching not only the mummy
but then the mummy returns and
i mean i know a lot about brendan
frazier just because i've been a huge
fan of his ever since i saw the movie in
theaters that i wanted to talk about
encino man didn't get enough support
from the brass and so now we're talking
about the mummy instead which is fine he
still actually does get a scene where he
looks like ling from encino man in this
movie he's just about to say that little
c no man shout out at the beginning but
but i mean yeah so so you follow sort of
what he's been through what his career
what his life has been through in the
last couple decades it's it's i'm so
happy that we are having this
appreciation for brendan frazier resume
and have fans all over the world say no
you know what we love the guy now and we
loved his movies back in the 90s i think
this might be a little bit of lovefest
guys i i have to say so if you're not in
for that you might you might want to
just put us turn us down a little bit
but eric striffler creator and co-host
of pretty much it his youtube channel he
is with us today and so eric i have to
ask you is rotten tomatoes wrong about
the mummy rotten tomatoes is wrong 60
what was it 61 percent yes it's a
travesty it's disgusting
and uh i have a huge problem with that
good luck that is not a passing grade is
it that's not a passing grade it's
barely a d it's barely a d no you you
still get a degree with a 61 percent i'm
and and i know from personal experience
okay you still get a diploma if you have
a d minus average yeah but you're not
getting any good jobs just remember that
nobody is recommending you for the like
coveted internship with a great job i
have many great jobs
none of which is what you went to school
for though but that is this industry
let's be honest uh
mark though let's go ahead and use that
that jesuit and uh wake forest education
of yours sir if you don't mind and give
us
the plot breakdown and the pertinent
partners of the mummy if it is a baptist
school i don't know if it was first or
so it's it's not affiliated with the
baptist church at all so we might as
well get into speaking of religion we're
going all the way back to bc times which
is even before bart starr led the
packers to the very first super bowl
championship this is like i don't know
the 1200s bc you got this high priest
ammo tap and emo tep
you know what guys am i right he has an
affair with the one person he's not
supposed to have an affair with so he
gets cursed for all eternity he's buried
alive it's not a good situation back
then in thebes which is in egypt and so
then you cut to slightly more modern
times where now we are in a.d and we
have brendan fraser around the 1900s
1920s i'd say he's an adventurer and he
gets very close because he is being
chased by an army gets very close to
kind of discovering this sort of lost
city then he gets locked up for a couple
years and then there's this librarian
played by rachel vice and her brother
they decide to go on this quest to
discover this lost city as well because
they have part of a map they run into
brennan fraser they pale him out of jail
and now we're off on this adventure
where it's a race against time it's a
race against other factions and once we
get to that city it's also a fight
against pure
cursed mummified
evil to survive and it's a roller king
adventure that feels in the vein of
indiana jones and maybe it's one of
those movies that the film jungle cruise
is like hey we want to kind of be like
indiana jones but maybe a little bit of
the mummy vibe too
released back in 1999 and jaclyn the
kids still love it today
i am with that that that incredible
synopsis mark although i will say
because it's like maybe like the more
classic film fan in me let's be honest
uh actually the mummy was ripping off
romancing the stone which was ripping
off uh sierra madre so it's like it's
all a rip-off of a rip-off of a rip-off
but that is neither that is neither here
nor there
uh let's go ahead and bring uh eric back
to us so you gave us a little bit of a
tease of why rotten tomatoes is wrong
but like break it down for us why do you
love this film why do you feel that it's
wrong well i should say right out of the
gate here uh you're since this is an
audio medium you'll have to read it for
me but i'm going to stand up and show
you what i'm wearing real quick if you
could describe it as you see it what are
you seeing here oh i see i see brendan
fraser and rachel vice on a t-shirt and
it says the mummy 1999 is perfect yeah
that is a great shirt sir and they i
wear this proudly everywhere i go
this does go up on youtube and like on
our streaming platform oh and oh so
people will get to see that we'll get to
see it yes i get i get compliments
everywhere i go i can tell you just even
my opinion aside i get compliments
everywhere i go wearing this shirt i was
just at a bar recently and the bartender
was absolutely loving it and so uh
people are still loving it people are
still talking about it um so it's really
it's not just me that i think i'm
speaking for the people here when i say
that this thing needs to be higher this
uh score and you said the audience
scores only 75 but i think that it's
only because like rotten tomatoes this
is all uh everything with with the mummy
is all um
back you know you have to go back and
review it again if you if you want it to
be like really coming up on rotten
tomatoes and i don't think people are
going back if if rotten tomatoes was
around when it came out i guarantee that
all the scores would be much higher i
think that um uh the critics scores
maybe would be higher but the audience
score would be through the roof i think
i think
yes i agree with you on that one um also
though real quick i want to shout out
producey lucy because she was absolutely
losing it when she got to see your shirt
like literally stood up in the chair
i know i wanted to keep it a surprise oh
that blew me away listen i i'm feeling
the love right now this movie i'm gonna
steal from stefan from snl this movie
has everything it's got sexy suspenders
it's got rachel weiss's eyebrows it's
got a sexy mummy and arnold voss lou is
that okay yeah yeah his little chest and
his little tom it's got
character the great character actor in
all of steven summers films from the era
yeah
yeah it's got sand
yeah mascara beetles
i don't even wanna i honestly feel like
the scarabs like go out of my head
because they're so freaky and disgusting
it really is such a great like that's
scarier in a lot of ways than the mummy
but yeah yeah you don't want the mummy's
not crawling into your brain at least i
know
mark uh i think i know the answer to
this because i i know you're a man of
taste but go ahead and tell us is rotten
tomatoes wrong about the mummy i'll be
honest with you jacqueline eric lucy's
you know i always am 100 shoot from the
hip honesty i think ryan tomatoes is
exactly right i think they are exactly
right with this movie i think i can get
it to fresh but if this movie was like
57 58
i'd say rotten tomatoes is right is that
61
i think rotten tomatoes is just fine i
think the movie's good i think it's
enjoyable do i think it's an all-time
classic no do i think it needs to be
hailed as this incredible life-changing
generation defining movie no it's a it's
a fun adventure that's got you know a
little bit of cheese to it a little bit
of fun to it i love brendan fraser and
rachel vice as the leads they're my my
favorite part of the movie i also love
that arnold vaslu was one of the bad
guys in the van damme classic hard
target so that is a nice attraction but
i just i again it's a nice movie to
watch i don't know that it has to be
this incredibly
hailed and revered movie in 2021 am i a
bad person well can we just say also
arnold vasily villain in age and cody
banks i just want to make sure that's
out there too oh i forgot about agent
cody he's like a side villain
he's like he's like uh jasper the guy
rufus
from the holidays from the holidays he
was kind of typecast as a villain but he
does it very well uh mark you hurt me um
you heard me
uh i'm not gonna say that your opinion
is incorrect but re-watching this film
last night i just could not just i just
brought tomatoes as wrong it is such a a
fast-moving
it it really has this incredible pace to
it that felt like
you're on the adventure with them which
i really love in these adventure type
movies also i will correct the record i
said sierra madre i meant to say african
queen which is the humphrey bogart
going down the river one excuse me it is
early in the morning and it's already
award season so just so you know guys my
brain capacity goes downhill from here
to the oscars but
but i do think it's wrong and and the
great thing about it is you can't cast
the kind of chemistry that rachel and
brendan fraser can you can't cast him to
be this lovable rogue like you could
just you either are harrison ford you
either are brendan fraser you are
humphrey bogart or you aren't like you
can't or michael douglas in romancing
the stone and and so i feel like it was
a really perfect formula
that granted was simplistic and we also
have to look this is a 20-plus year-old
movie that has cgi that is pretty
passable considering how old it is i'm
like telling you cgi at that time
was not this consistent in fact one of
the sequels scorpion king wishes that it
had the cgi of this movie gosh oh and we
will discuss that one there um but
before we go ahead and break down all
the movie talk and such we want to go
ahead and take a trip back to what the
critics and audiences were saying with
our favorite segment from our review
curation manager mr tim ryan here we go
with two minutes with time
[Music]
few would make the claim that the 1999
version of the mummy lives up to the
eerie power of the 1932 boris karloff
classic but it's going for something
completely different combining the silly
thrills of an old-school swashbuckler
with state-of-the-art special effects
for the time whether or not it succeeded
is up for debate
it's at 61 on the tomato meter with 101
reviews but it does have a 75 audience
score
so what did the critics have to say in a
fresh review gary thompson of the
philadelphia daily news wrote the mummy
quite shamelessly combines the imagery
and serialized thrills of the indiana
jones movies with the frenetic special
effects energy of the evil dead movies
and has quite a bit of fun doing so
however in a rotten review todd mccarthy
a variety wrote that the mummy tries to
have it both ways sending up the
adventure genre for laughs while also
going for some mild shocks but the sand
slips through its fingers on both counts
the rotten tomatoes critic's consensus
reads it's difficult to make a
persuasive argument for the mummy as any
kind of meaningful cinematic achievement
but it's undeniably fun to watch
well
that's a wrap back to you folks
well
i have to say i think tim definitely you
know got the vibes in the feel but i
don't know if tim is a big mummy fan
either i'm i'm curious about this one he
didn't sound thrilled he didn't he
didn't sound through it
it was a good finale with that's a wrap
i appreciated that
i mean also let's talk about it too um
this was in the infancy of rotten
tomatoes like like rotten tomatoes had
just barely started up when this film uh
was sort of becoming into the mainstream
these were in the baby baby days uh
that's what i was wondering yeah that's
what i was when i was saying like i
wonder if you know rotten tomatoes was
as prevalent then as it is now i wonder
how it would look that definitely
impacts it you know
absolutely like again we were out there
definitely not you know the huge thing
that it is now but we were out there and
uh there's still a lot of love to be had
about this film so let's go ahead and
talk about why we love it and we will
try to shout down mark
in our movie stuff i said it could be
fresh i'm fine with it being fresh
that's not enough not for this movie sir
but it's okay i don't even need to come
for you that hard the internet will take
care of you on this one yeah you're done
man
you got this shout out early on from
someone asking to do this and now you've
lost a fan i mean literally they're
going to turn on you sorry
happens to us all
all right
all right let's go ahead and go over to
movie talk cue the music
[Music]
okay i kind of talked about this a
little bit uh when i was talking about
why rotten tomatoes is wrong but like
this movie just moves and it seems it
just goes from great action set piece or
like really interesting fun setup to
like great action set piece interesting
fun setup and it just the pace of it is
incredible i mean the movie itself maybe
takes place over the course of a long
weekend maybe you know like a few days
but um eric what what is your favorite
scene from the movie favorite moment
that you're like yes uh look there's so
many the whole thing is burned into my
brain
this is
so okay so i will say this what's
interesting is i think i saw the mummy
returns first because i i was just old
enough to see it in theaters and then i
didn't necessarily realize or care at
that age that i was seeing a sequel
before the first one and it doesn't
really matter that much you know you get
the gist but uh when i went back and
watched the mummy i watched it at home
and i remember like vividly watching it
the first time and uh and every time i
watch it it feels like i'm transported
right back to that like it never loses
its charm it's always got the same charm
from the very first time i watched it
and so it's hard to pick one scene but
the first thing that always comes to
mind because it feels like the type of
thing that i maybe have quoted more
often than anything it's the scene where
uh
you're gonna know exactly what it is i'm
trying to think of a way to say it where
it won't exact immediately tell you what
it is but the river when they're on
either side of the river uh and uh
brendan frazier of course is on one side
with uh with the horses oh sorry uh
benny's on one side with the horses and
he says oh conor my mother looks like
who has all the horses and then of
course brendan fraser says hey betty
looks like you're on the wrong side of
the river and i feel like i say that in
my life maybe once a week
it somehow makes its way in once a week
wow
it looks to me like i've got all the
horses
hey benny
looks to me like you're on the wrong
side of the river
[Music]
that's a moment and also his reaction
kicks at the water uh that is a moment
that i feel like
gets everything
that encompasses like the feeling of the
movie where you're like genuinely like
oh no they don't have the horses what
are they gonna do but then immediately
there's a big laugh like you said it's
sort of sending up the genre a little
bit um and uh obviously you got the
scary stuff in there as well when i was
a kid it was scary but i feel like that
scene is is one that really sticks out
to me for sure i i love that you that
you point to that scene because that was
one of the scenes that i totally forgot
about when i was re-watching the movie
where this is basically the part of the
film where we've rescued brendan frazier
from captivity where we see him get
arrested in the very first scene in the
movie and he looked like the caveman
link from encino man when he was in the
cage and then we get him out just before
his neck is stretched in a hanging yeah
so
he's back to being suave brendan frazier
which is one of my favorite scenes in
this movie too it's just that is that is
that change from from rachel vice seeing
this guy who tried to kiss her when he
was in a cage and then they're like i
don't i don't know about this guy then
he shows up and he's back to being like
suave cool that brendan frazier the
marquee movie star that we know and love
and then we get on the boat and so the
movie does a really nice job of setting
up these sort of factions that this is
gold treasure that everybody and their
brother and sister are going to be
racing after and so it's like a nascar
race it's like you have a bunch of cars
that are all vrooming towards this one
lost city to find this treasure or to
discover the artifact or just to whether
they're appreciating history like the
librarian character played by rachel or
it's just they're treasure hunting like
a lot of the other americans or it's
brendan fraser you just have this thing
like that you're like hey i was so close
before i can do this again
i love that setup but then i'll play off
of eric scene jacqueline because i'll
say what i really did enjoy and it does
harken back to raiders of the lost ark
very clearly is when it's just before
dawn and we're all lined up with our
camels and we're all looking at each
other and we're saying okay what is
happening here are we just in the middle
of the desert and then the sun comes up
and it shows us the city that we
couldn't see before
sunrise and then we're all just off to
the races
look at that can you believe omenoptra
here we go again
[Music]
that was a cool scene that really got me
into the feel of the movie so as people
know who've listened to this show before
my opinions are very malleable i think
more people could stand to have
malleable movie opinions like mine and
so i can't be won over and y'all already
starting to get me with the pacing of
this movie because i agree eric and
jacqueline i think that this movie does
move brilliantly
and look there's just so many movies now
like there's been this twitter thing
going on about like you know i will die
on the hill that no movie needs to be
over two hours and i will say that like
i am not that person but i think a lot
of movies that should have been under
two hours aren't
um because people forget this pulp
fiction is a three-hour movie people
forget that pulp fiction is a three-hour
movie but tell me when you're watching
pulp fiction if you feel that no you
feel every vignette you're you're in it
you're invested because every time they
switch to a new setup you're like what's
gonna happen next right
with this character and how is it gonna
tie into the big story and this movie
does the same it's just brilliant pacing
and it takes colorful writing to make
that happen but in the moments when it's
not moving it's still interesting and my
scene is actually one of those like not
moving moments is when they get to
haminatra after um rachel vice's
character you know with her little camel
like
she like makes her way up there which i
loved i was like yes take it to the boys
um
and they you know they found the mummy
the americans have you know enacted the
curse but they haven't yet
read from the book
and
they are standing there with glenn
fittich
a bottle of glenn finish and it's rick
and it's her and she's like mean it this
is something that gets left out of a lot
of movies it's how these two characters
sort of fall in love a little bit and
her saying you know mean it and like
throwing her thing and my favorite part
is when she comes up so drunk that is
brilliant acting and she's just like i
am proud of what i am and i am
a librarian that is i loved it i loved
it so much i understand that girl as
somebody who also knocks over things
unintentionally but likes books more
than people i i lived for that character
i thought it was so so well done and i
absolutely love that scene what are you
doing here
oh
silk i
i may not be
an explorer
or an adventurer or a treasure seeker or
a gun fighter
mr o'connell
but i
am proud
of what i am
and what is that
i
am a librarian
okay but she also
fell in love with this guy not when he
was smooth brendan frazier here we go
a
barbaric sort of
hulking mass of a locked up
felon and he grabs her
and forces her to kiss him and she's
still thinking about that kiss when
we're on the boat that recruits eric's
scene and so listen she doesn't like
that she likes when he shaves and the
music swells she hears it in her own
ears
but wait a minute to be fair one of the
biggest books of that time is a book
called the chic
which is about a man that literally
abducts a white woman kind of similarly
to brendan fraser in that opening scene
this sort of 1920s woman she is the
reason why romance novels today are so
problematic because that is all those
heifers wanted that is all those heifers
wanted they were liv they lived in such
these gilded cages that the idea of some
dude coming literally to come through
the bars to come get them
better than any fantasy they could think
of on their own so i actually say that
is that is true to form if brendan
fraser came through the bars of my
window i would be
down to
go hang out down to clown down to clown
baby i would say like at least because a
lot of other movies might not have done
this at least brandon frazier's
character had the class so once he is on
the boat and he showered and he's
thinking in the right frame of mind
again that he says like uh maybe it
wasn't the best idea and so but then but
then immediately she's like oh it wasn't
a good kiss she's been thinking about
that kiss she didn't even want clean
shaven brendan fra she wants caveman
encino man brandon i'm not again i find
that that is actually well written that
like her being so put off by it no that
is the biggest and best thing that has
happened in her life that had anything
to do with sex i guarantee you
i would also say you're kind of
reminding me of something i have a
problem with with movies today is that
like
characters can be flawed as well uh and
i feel like today a lot of um not that
this is necessarily a specific thing
that i love about the mummy but just
what you're talking about here um you
know it like any a criticism that
criticism is like uh it's okay to
disagree with a character or disagree
with their intentions or what they want
and like sometimes we want things that
we shouldn't you know whatever in a
weird situation um and i think that
today everything's a little too clean
like you mentioned um jungle cruise
earlier i think right which is cruz by
the way
the introduction of emily blunt's
character
literally copy pasted from the
introduction of racial racial vice
character from the mummy let's be clear
um but uh like we're talking like on the
the latter in the library vibes the
exact same thing um but uh
it's sort of like in that movie like
you
they're perfect they're clean like
everything is just like you know squeaky
clean i i feel like in something like
that and then back then yeah you could
like disagree with their intentions or
disagree with their actions but brendan
or rachel uh but uh that's okay i think
that's fine that's a great point and and
i would say that i i don't think it'd be
out of character for henry jones jr or
senior for that matter to attempt the
same thing in an indiana jones movie so
totally i i don't i don't think it's i'm
not going to bury the movie like they
buried arnold vaslu but it's just like
really that's that's the thing that's
the kiss really
i mean look again uh
i'm not gonna be i again i was i was
with it i believed it um also too like i
i kind of feel for the characters just
because all of the people in this were
also having to deal with the fact that
they were acting against tennis balls at
a time when acting against tennis balls
was like not a thing
like like it's so funny i always use
this quote but jake gyllenhaal when he
did um mysterio and spider-man he was
like turning to tom holland who's been
like jake gyllenhaal did his first movie
when he was like six and this dude has
been doing movies for better part of
three decades but he had never done such
a heavy cgi effort right he's turning to
tom holland like hey um how
do i do this yeah i don't envy that yeah
yeah
but look at this i mean i think it's a
testament to this film because yeah they
didn't know what emoteof was gonna look
like they didn't know if the cgi at that
point was even gonna live up to that
this was such a new medium i mean they
thought they could be in like you know a
bad version of like hans coming off of
the tower and die hard they didn't know
um but i think the vfx really is a
testament to why this film is still
beloved because you don't feel that like
oh
oh yeah tell me there and mark you tell
me when you you just watched it you know
you're having some problems with it you
buy that the mummy's in the room with
them don't you
i do and i i have a very impressive tv
that i've bragged about on the show
before and the visual effects i okay so
i it's hard for me in my mind to
separate the mummy in 1999 from the
movie that i saw in theaters the same
theater three weeks later which is star
wars episode one the phantom menace i
went to go see the mummy i wanted to see
it i liked brandon frazier but i was
also just sort of pregaming how i was
scouting uh locations for where the best
place in the theater to sit would be for
this magical religious star wars
experience i was going to have something
like a technical demo you were yeah you
were like doing like the all the
speakers were like firing to figure out
where to sit it's exactly what i was
doing and then the movie starts and i'm
having a good time in the movie but the
visual effects i'm glad that we brought
up that this was 1999 and how
groundbreaking cgi was at the time
and
if you want to know how hard it is to
act against tennis balls especially back
in the day when people were just
pioneering it go watch star wars episode
one the phantom menace yeah and
you don't get any chemistry
in that movie like you do with a number
of the characters in the mummy so that's
a big point in favor of the mummy i
think the mummy is is should be higher
on the tomato meter than the phantom
menace you know i would have both of
them around the same place and so
the phantom menace has obviously bigger
highlights for me but if you're talking
about the mummy and the visual effects
and it holding up yes i think it does
and i think that it's a movie that you
can put on i think that's why future
generations maybe even the eric
strifflers of the world who are younger
than me have fallen in love with these
movies because you can put it on the
small screen and you can still buy the
movie the the visual effects do not get
in the way of the movie and that's a
that's a big achievement to say 22 years
after the fact yeah yeah i think
honestly i think a lot of effects from
back then are better than today i don't
i can't put my finger on it i don't know
exactly what it is maybe it's because
it's so much i don't want to say easier
obviously and like you know disrespect
all the incredible hard work that goes
into visual effects but uh it's it's
more accessible i guess like the
technology has gotten easier uh and so
it's almost taken for granted and i
think back then everything was a little
more intentional maybe that's the word
everything felt more intentional and
yeah like so when you see uh the first
introduction of the mummy or any time
that he's on there and it's the full you
know the cg mummy i full it's imposing
it's scary you don't even think about
the fact that this is an effect uh you
you just are like there's the mummy the
mummy is in the room with them and uh
and you mentioned you know technically
this is
a remake quote-unquote or reimagining of
the original boris carla film right
kinda uh so that's the idea i guess
technically you know a new spin on it
but uh in the same way that i feel like
people you know the original mummy was
imposing from i guess that's the 30s
probably uh this mummy i think is just
as imposing even though he's not
technically in the room yeah like you
said it's you're acting with a tennis
ball they look scared i believe it i buy
it and it makes me completely buy that
he is in the room uh
spooking it up
it's it's really funny too for a
boogeyman movie which you know universal
is known for they're the one that did
the little monster verse with like the
mummy the invisible man and dracula and
still doing it you know to this day but
i think what's interesting about this
one is it's the chase he's coming for
you it's it's that aspect of it and i
think
i mean i don't know is there there's
like so many effects that happen with it
because it's the mummy but it's also the
sand effect and if i'm being really
honest one of my other favorite scenes
is the scene when rick
or i don't know if it's the one where
rick does it on purpose or it's the one
where he just stumbles across the cat
and he like shows and then he does that
like i'm leaving
when he holds it up and he's like here
look at this i don't know if it's that
one or just the one where the cat walks
across the piano piano right yeah either
one but the effect of like the face sort
of like pushing by that particular scene
i thought was really great and also the
sand scene at the beginning when brenda
frazier is at haminatra in like the
opening montage and
he's like basically being attacked by
the sand below and then they show that
like deep sunken sand face thing like i
think like a lot of the
the mummy effect scenes also sort of
like make the movie even when you know
again he's not really attacking them at
that moment
all right let's go ahead and think about
another thing that folks are still
talking about which is why people are
still obsessed with this movie uh
i mean i don't know eric what do you
think like is there is it is it just
because we love brendan frazier and he
kind of disappeared is it because there
hadn't been movies like this in a while
is it because it was also like this
millennial nostalgia-filled generation
that we are a part of not you sir i
don't know you're a millennial right i'm
30. okay yeah
okay well what is what does that put you
i don't want to put any pressure on you
but this is this is my big question
about this movie it's not whether it's
an enjoyable rollicking adventure that
swashbuckles its way for two hours it's
why is it just like hail as this beloved
all-time sort of classic from the last
20 years that's that that's the that's
the hurdle i'm trying to get over yeah i
think honestly i think a thing that's
been really missing from movies today
and again i have to bring it up you
brought it up and it and it makes sense
jungle cruise is trying to be this
basically you know it's trying to be the
mummy for today i think that the big
difference is that uh you're in you're
really more invited along for the ride
with with a movie like the mummy uh
you're invited along for the ride it
feels like the people making the movie
are like running along with you through
this thing like it doesn't feel like
you're just watching it feels like
you're really enveloped by it um and uh
and i feel like that's the big thing is
that what you you are
wrapped up to use that pun again uh
wrapped up in it in a way that makes you
feel involved uh and and there's more of
a like outside looking in quality to
movies that are trying to do it today um
i i i don't i mean i i hope that makes
sense i think that that's a thing that's
really missing these days and the mummy
gets perfectly right like right from the
start it's the uh you know it draws you
in with the with the humor obviously
brendan's charm and uh and the the
effects the effects being again that you
actually buy that he's in the room uh
the mummy and um and so i think that i
think that's what really
obviously outside of the movie itself
there's a nostalgia element like people
are remembering like that time of their
lives and stuff and if you're at a
certain age that's that might be
childhood so you're remembering maybe
like a simpler time uh but
um it's just not sort of like there's no
cynicism there's absolutely no cynicism
at all uh it is completely you can feel
the heart in it uh you can feel uh its
intention is
is um genuine and uh it like literally
it almost feels like everyone in the
room today you know there's so many
different people in the room that are
trying to do this we gotta promote a
product we gotta sell toys we gotta do
this we gotta set up sequels and with
this movie it feels like everyone in the
room was like we gotta entertain the
people and that's exactly what i think
because the uh the the lasting impact
from it pure entertainment yeah
yeah pure just no ulterior motives just
entertainment turn your brain off if you
took a history class once upon a time
maybe you'll get some sort of juice out
of the fact that we are basing this
around
actual things and rituals that could
have happened in ancient egypt so i get
all of that but the standing legacy of
this movie to me because jacqueline also
compared a lot of these to romancing the
stone and which is
it or jewel denial as well which is like
those are fun movies but i i don't know
that people i would put this more in
that category where it's a fun movie to
watch and then i'm going to move on with
my life as opposed to something that is
as iconic as indiana jones yeah i would
agree with that it's not look indiana
jones is
it puts it in a different characteristic
when you're talking about john williams
steven spielberg and harrison ford like
let's be honest um and george lucas
along for you know the producing and so
on and so forth but
it does have its own little niche and i
do think it was a movie of a certain
generation that
that particular time i feel like from 95
to like 2002 the things that people are
nostalgic about from that time period
this is when people were in high school
this is when you know that generation
was in high school and that generation
is the most nostalgic generation that
we've had like gen z people are not near
as nostalgic about the things like the
way that millennials are and i also
think that they're the ones driving a
lot of this on the internet and it's
what's great is like you know getting
ready to watch this it's readily
available the mummy is like played very
often on like tnt and so like it's a
movie that like you can find fairly
easily so i would say that's part of it
but
who are we to judge we're just going to
love it i don't know why i like popcorn
i just like popcorn behind me i have a
very hot take about this movie so again
this movie came out think about when
this movie came out 1999 three weeks
before star wars but it's like right
it's that first big summer blockbuster
right so a bunch of kids starting to get
out of school and there's a whole
generation of kids that maybe are going
on their very first date or they can
drive now and they have like the summer
to do that you're not going to see star
wars because back then there was still
just a little bit of a nerd stigma
around star wars it doesn't exist as
much today a little bit a little bit but
you also a lot of it
you could even get tickets to go see
phantom menace because it was sold out
for three weeks and so the mummy is like
the core date movie where you go and so
a lot i have a feeling a lot of couples
got together because
of the mummy because they went to go see
the mummy and it's just got that
adventure tone where a boy and a girl
are falling in love against all odds
against everything attacking them they
sort of see eye and they have great
chemistry i think that's one of the
reasons why there is such heavy
nostalgia for this movie i think was a
lot of people's first date yeah i also i
will say i think the internet has a lot
to do with it too because back then you
wouldn't be able to know what everybody
thinks immediately you could really only
talk to the people around you you could
talk to other people that saw it and i
think that it was at the this you know
perfect time where over the next decade
the internet really came up and i think
that like
probably early you know you kind of
nowadays on the internet you find your
people you know what i mean like you if
you have like a niche thing that you
love or or even like a broad thing that
you love you find out oh other people
like this too and i think that that
happened with the mummy as well and
that's why it's popular today you see it
on the internet and stuff uh a lot um uh
i think it's it's one of those things
where it's like
loved it so much didn't know everybody
else enjoyed it as much as i did oh
let's all talk about it we didn't get to
talk about it then we can talk about it
now and i'll add two like to the
nostalgia thing i remember my parents
were in high school in the 70s and 80s
and that's when like star wars and
indiana jones came out so my dad
would share with me the films of his
childhood so to speak
and so i in the early 90s as a kid like
a tiny kid was watching star wars and
indiana jones then all of a sudden a few
years later the mummy comes out i'd been
waiting it was like why aren't movies
like this the mummy comes out and it's
like that same
feeling so it's like this
being in being a millennial i feel like
that's another aspect too it's like
our parents kind of opened the doors for
us and the amazing um
world of films coming out steven
spielberg and harrison ford movies
coming out in the 70s and 80s and it's
like that carried it through i think in
the mummy same sort of energy and to
borrow a song title from a great band i
think this movie now is the best of both
worlds because it came out in the lake
eric said 99 so it was before really you
had all of this like intense movie
scrutiny online had this movie come out
today with the 2021 lens there's a lot
of problematic elements of it but we
give movies a pass
if they were made before that was a hot
button issue that was brought to the
masses in a way that it is now and so if
there's whitewashing if they're pretty
much anybody who is not a white person
in this movie is is a villain
immediately well like we don't even
trust them we don't we don't want to
give them the benefit of the doubt and
so all of that is a problem
but because this movie came out at a
time where we know who it is we've
already seen the movie and we go back
and watch it i don't think that it's
judged as harshly which for better for
worse i mean again steven summers this
is probably the best movie he made you
know okay well you're forgetting about
van helsing but that's fine that's a
different
you
episode
gi joe the rise of cobra i mean this is
his opus yeah
yeah for sure for sure yeah and
definitely got him a lot of work going
going forward i mean the movie made
money it was a classic and we'll kind of
we'll kind of get into that um when we
break down uh when we break down for our
behind-the-scenes stuff so let's go
ahead and transition over to that one
because there's a lot that went into
this movie that we didn't even talk
about thus far even though we've talked
about a lot so brian qsf
[Music]
so as i mentioned this movie
we made a lot of money it made for
416 million at the box office worldwide
off of a 62 million dollar budget um but
some say maybe 80 either way still made
a ton uh sixth highest grossing film of
99
i i think this was a movie i definitely
saw in the theater i remember that
trailer for this movie was absolutely
incredible i was so invested the minute
i saw that trailer what about you mark
it was a theater you said it was a
theater one for you what about you eric
theater right well it's also the super
bowl spot too yes that's what it was
this had a super bowl and i and i
distinctly remember watching this uh
seeing the super bowl ad because it was
my freshman year in college that's my
age eric and we saw it and and we're
always like all gathered around the dorm
room and there's two commercials that i
remember from that super bowl one is a
mitsubishi commercial because they used
ozzie's crazy train in it the other one
was just that face of the sand with the
mummy and everybody freaking out and
losing their minds like that's gonna be
cool
yeah no i remember that one was that
also the year that they did 3d doritos
i think that was the one remember the
girl like she had the chip go into her
mouth like fly into her mouth
or something i got a research
what it was also the debut of family guy
was right after that
yeah
oh god family guy they hated them that
show at first i remember fox got in so
people were like what is this they were
not about it
uh and then you know 20 years later it
is still on the air
baby can't talk
um what's interesting about this one too
is for all the cgi it had what it didn't
have was those like oh this is not
really you doing your own stunts uh wide
shots because it seems like everybody in
the film rachel brendan everybody was
like i'm gonna do even the egyptologist
guy that was with her calling her the
plague he was even wheeled in a sword
like that was the other thing too i
really loved watching the stunts from
this one uh do you have a favorite sort
of you know watching brendan frazier be
linked in his awesomeness stunt mark
that you enjoyed i mean i i just i i
love the the stories of stunts behind
the scenes and and eric i don't know if
you saw this there was a stunt man that
like broke both their arms during this
movie like they were doing something and
just like
and and it sucks and like i hate hearing
stories like that but you're also like
man they really put them through a lot
but the final product was it worth it i
you know the movie made a crapload of
money so well also i didn't correct me
if i'm wrong but didn't brendan frazier
hurt himself a lot around this time by
doing these stunts like didn't he kind
of mess up i think he's gone on record
saying he kind of messed his body up a
bunch because he was like doing things
that may look you know i have all the
respect in the world for people that do
their own stunts but also
it can mess you up you know like there's
a way to do it right there's a and
there's you know if you're not a
professional stunt person that you know
you might do it wrong and i i uh so i
mean yeah it looks great but like you
said yeah is it worth it i mean yeah for
the movie sure but in life i remember he
said uh i uh that it really kind of
messed him up yeah several back
surgeries to sort of uh repair from that
if you haven't seen and shout out to
mark hoffmeyer who detailed this along
with uh an incredible documentary that
is a part of the the dvd blu-ray that i
possess ladies and gentlemen let me tell
you my love from the mummy goes deep um
there's a great doc that breaks down how
they did the vfx but there's a recent gq
article where brendan sort of details
like why he fell off and why folks are
so excited for his resurgence right now
he's about to be in a scorsese movie
like the guy's really coming back i
think with a vengeance in a really great
way but yeah he definitely talks about
how his body went through it for this
and
he's kind of a cautionary tale now um
for
i think that that sort of aspect of it
you could ruin your life in the in the
pursuit of your craft also i have to
shout out uh kevin o'connor
uh who plays benny oh that's his name
okay yeah kevin o'connor plays benny
first of all when i first saw this movie
i was staring at him and i was just like
who is this dude and he is
he's in two very girly movies that y'all
probably don't know but one of them is
peggy sue got married with kathleen
turner where she wakes up and nicholas
cage that was the last francis ford
coppola movie he ever did because
francis or coppola was so mad that
nicholas cage did that weird accent in
it
so he fired his nephew
and he was also in steel magnolias he
played daryl hannah's love interest in
that he played sammy but he had a
totally different physique in those
movies he lost a lot of weight in the
latter part of his career to the point
where like his first half of his career
he's a different looking actor from the
second half like you have to squint to
see it
and there's a great line that he
improvised in this movie apparently and
it's when brendan frazier is about to
shoot him because he's the one that sort
of
you know benedict arnold him at the very
beginning of the movie so brendan fraser
finds him on the boat when we're all
going back towards finding this lost
city and fraser just pulls a gun on he's
about to cap him right there and he's
like i think about my my my children and
that was improvised and so then fraser
plays off it and says you don't have any
kids he's like but maybe someday
it's a really fun exchange and you're
and you go back and watch that you're
like that was improvised they played it
so well
yeah he's he's a really underrated like
side guy in a lot of different stuff
he's great yeah yeah yeah and he's his
sliminess is very true to form in my
personal opinion like his sliminess is
what
did him in and what saved him because if
he wouldn't have just been greedy and
would just ridden off with that camel
and not gone back for more
he could have lived to see another day
but also being slimy with him going
through literally every religion like as
a way to sort of make sure that he was
going to make it to some form of an
afterlife is what allowed him to survive
and become immitep's little little [ __ ]
for
that movie
when he has the little all the different
pendants and stuff is incredible yeah
when he's just like one of these has to
work one of these has to work yeah he's
just an enterprising young man i mean he
he made a cottage industry out of taking
stupid americans like me who were like
oh i saw indiana jones i want to go look
for treasure and he's like all right
i'll take you halfway there and then you
can dine around and i'll go find the
next boat it's like
i i do not hold any
will against benny whatsoever i'll also
give a big shout out to my boy arnold
basler who i did love from hard target
and he showed up in this i'm like that's
the guy from hard target but he also he
was so apparently he wasn't in the best
of shape when they were when he
initially got cast for this movie and
the first time that he tried on his
costume
it was like basically a a glorified
g-string and so the costume designer
went back to stephen sommers and they
said hey uh arnold we we might have a
fat mommy he we we need you know to do
something about this mummy and so if
oslo just like started getting in great
shape he'd walk his dog all around elway
like i did during the pandemic and you
just get in better shape and so he got
in mummy shape by basically walking his
dog around l.a because he tried the
costume on once but he also like tried
to do an approximation of ancient egypt
like the way that they would speak back
then with a professor from like uc davis
or something like that so he really went
in deep and and i appreciate that about
somebody who again you could just be a
throwaway villain but he invested into
this craft and i think that the final
product reveals that so are you are you
in mummy shape by the way now after
walking your dog around
i mean i feel like a mummy now like
different kind of mummy shape i don't
know
words
i just remember in the research too he
was like
i'm playing a high priest like there's
no way those guys were fit uh me being
soft would be perfect and then he was
like i'll be naked for the whole movie
he's thinking of it like a real serious
thing but meanwhile it's just like a fun
thing yeah yeah
uh eric you got any behind-the-scenes
facts i hear you got some stuff on this
one well i'll tell you what it's it's uh
less of a behind-the-scenes thing and
more of um almost sort of um
sideways slantier but the
the one of the uh something i wanted to
make sure i got in here an enduring
element of this movie
is
uh two roller coasters on each coast uh
the mummy ride uh in uh in universal
studios hollywood and orlando um and
that
you know you just made me think of it
because you're asking behind the scenes
i don't know if you've been on it
recently first of all it's my favorite
ride uh i think it's my favorite ride
ever and i'm definitely gonna get a
tattoo at some point that is like in
brackets uh mummy uh mummy wush brendon
screams or something from the ending of
the ride the one in orlando specifically
but the whole uh uh in case you don't
remember the whole um idea of the ride
like the queue is that you're behind the
scenes of the movie like they're
basically saying that on the set there
was a bunch of spooky stuff going on and
the ride literally again maybe just the
orlando one it's been a while since i've
been on the hollywood one it literally
ends with you know you finish the ride
and there's a screen in front of you and
it's brendan fraser thanking you for
riding the ride saying he would have had
a better time if he had gotten a cup of
coffee like he's on the set of the movie
basically uh and so in my mind growing
up that is like kind of part of the
behind the scenes of the movie part of
the movie is the ride in my mind um and
so i don't know if you guys like that
right if you've been on it recently but
that's i wanted to make sure i got that
in there because it is incredible oh
it's fantastic it is fantastic and i'm
not a huge theme park guy in my adult
life just because i have naps to take in
sports to watch but when i get to a
theme park i do embrace it whether it's
at disneyland or whether it's universal
studios which is i live in the shadow of
and so i went there a couple years ago
with molly's mom and we went to the
wizarding world and we got butterbeers
it was great but the mummy ride was the
headlines i'd never been on it before
and it
i do joke about it that it's kind of
like if you get in the bedroom with me
it's very fast it's memorable and then
you're done and the movie literally is
45 the ride is 45 seconds long it's like
you start you go zero to sixty super
fast you go back the other way it is
such an enjoyable ride and then you're
just like all right uh that that was
very quick and this is
such an enjoyable ride yeah yeah it's
i i think maybe the movie could have
benefited a little more from the brevity
of the ride i think this movie could
have been
about 20 25 minutes slimmer really yeah
what really how how is that possible
so
good good i'm gl and honestly it's too
short
it is it is too short
yeah you know i understand equals well
so i was just definitely
don't return love for the sequels okay
well i'll tell you well no the tomb of
the dragon emperor we don't even talk
about that that never happened but uh
the
primarily just because they recast the
actress yeah maria bello is great but it
just like it just doesn't fit it doesn't
work yeah but i like i did put on a
little bit of mummy returns last night
after i finished the mummy and and i
found that just as enjoyable so
how about that everybody who loves the
mommy i will defend the mummy returns as
well and that movie should definitely be
fresh so i feel okay so i feel like
those two that's what i was gonna say is
i think i mentioned earlier i think i
saw the mummy returns before i saw the
mummy because i saw it in theaters and
then went back and watched the mummy i'm
pretty sure i was at an age where i was
like oh this doesn't look too scary and
i i went back and caught up on them but
uh i will say the mummy returns you were
talking about you know like the mummy
could be shorter could be longer um but
when i jokingly was you know thinking it
could be longer it honestly kind of
feels like the mummy returns is a good
enough sequel that it feels like an
extension of the first movie it almost
feels like they're two in one it when i
think of the mummy i don't just think of
the first movie i think of both um and
uh i guess the biggest criticism
probably of the sequel is the kid i
think you know there's a big thing going
on at the time where they would just add
a kid as the protagonist you know like
the audience surrogate and i know that
was a big complaint a lot of people had
about that movie and to other movies
even today that happens but um as far as
the swashbuckling goes the vibe of it
the effects everything aside from the
rock obviously at the end um the i do
feel like you it's almost like you get
uh two movies in one you know like when
you see like a box set and target or
something like that it feels like the
perfect like you could watch one and
then the other without stopping and it's
just like a perfect double feature so i
think that that adds that retroactively
adds to the mummy
i agree
i agree have you been on the ride
jacqueline have you been on the i was
just about to say i was on the one in
orlando in another one i want to make it
clear the orlando one is longer and
better it is longer it is longer
it is definitely better so i was on the
one in orlando is it still there
it did right it's still there they just
updated actually the uh the visual
elements of it like the projection stuff
love that love that so no i was that
i've been to the one in 99 back in
another life when i worked for real
corporate overlords uh we did our
convention
at uh orlando and it was universal
studios and we all got together and did
our little
celebration some fun happened that night
yeah do you like the part where you get
like sprayed in the face yes i hate it
is that supposed to be blood or glass i
don't know i never know because it's
right when the glass breaks and i'm like
is this supposed to be the person's
blood or glass breaking i don't know
what this is i just i'm always for a
nice mist during a
theme park ride but now i got to try the
one at universal i think the big
question is this because we can debate
the movie merits all we want the mummy i
think pales in comparison to the great
indiana jones films but the indiana
jones ride versus the mummy ride yeah oh
geez that's tough that is tough uh i
haven't done indiana jones i don't know
oh my gosh it's incredible well our so
that's uh only in on this coast on the
west coast uh so the mummy ride
the better mummy ride is on the east
coast the the indiana jones rides on the
west coast so it's it's almo it almost
feels like um
it's hard to compare them because it
feels like different worlds theme park
wise but uh the
one's a roller coaster so i'll give it
that i think i still got to go with the
mummy even though the indiana jones ride
is incredible the mummy ride is is a
full-on roller coaster in the yeah i'm
going with the mummy ride as well for
the ride itself but indiana jones is
better because as soon as you get off
when you're in the exit line you walk
out and boom right there is the dole
whip stand which is why you go to
disneyland
i love that
i absolutely love that dole whip stan
i'm about it all right kids that's it
for us on behind the scenes talk the fun
is not over though ladies and gentlemen
we are about to open up our mailbag and
hear from you so brian cue the music
[Music]
alrighty then so
that's it just that one little note lucy
i just want to make sure yeah we're
keeping it short and sweet today
please leave this in because i literally
was like wait a minute this is not
i almost did something shorter somebody
just emailed me yesterday and all they
said was event horizon
i
short and sweet up about it that gets
the point across
when you email us you can email us rt is
wrong at rottentomatoes.com by the way
is wrong at rottentomatoes.com you
you're allowed to type words if you want
to to defend the movie that you're
asking us to review that always helps
i'm just saying normally we get these
like magnum opuses of like this is why
and i love you but ray vickers man you
are short sweet and to the point he just
says would you guys consider doing a
show on the movie adventures in
babysitting with elizabeth shu thanks
you guys are awesome i mean
we don't need much more there's a lot of
people that contend that this is a
karate kid
sequel
that this is what happened to ally after
she disappears in the karate kid too if
this is a karate kid sequel then this is
the best karate kid movie ever made
because adventures in babysitting i'll
tell you what if i'm ranking on-screen
babysitters you can throw mary poppins
at me you can even throw christina
applegate and don't tell mom the
babysitter's dead i'll put mrs sterk
from the beginning of that movie in the
conversation they all
are the mummy to elizabeth shoes indiana
jones of babysitters elizabeth shu is
the all-time cinematic breadwinner when
it comes to babysitters i love that
movie we should definitely talk about
the very first on-screen appearance of
thor
yes yes that is the first honor eric
have you seen the movie young man no i
and i'm curious now about the thor
aspect of it i'm not telling you anymore
you gotta go watch the movie got it
also let me also add i it's great that
you love her as a babysitter mark but is
it because she flashes the kids because
if i recall correctly she flashes the
kids in like the first
five minutes of that movie
i
i'm gonna
i'm gonna contend that i don't remember
that
happening you have to pay extra for that
i think she does my parents just tape it
off tv and not show me the full
adventures in babies she does i do think
she does she is the sexiest woman alive
even today yeah even the boys i am not
yes she is oh yeah yeah she's got i'm
ready let me see some elizabeth i am
totally down to do that episode if my if
my husband ever left me it would be for
her
ever since karate kid he was like she's
the one that's the hall pass yeah lucy's
husband who by the way big fan of
eric and pretty much it oh yeah
that's fantastic i love that
he he got me into it he's a big fan
that's awesome i'm a big fan
i like it all right ladies and gentlemen
that is going to be
it for us today um eric sir thank you so
much for joining us this was so much fun
thank you so much for having me
yeah i could talk about the mummy all
day i love it thank you for having me
this is great um but before you go tell
folks where uh what you're working on
where they can find you and if you can
please sir give us a movie
recommendation because we know you are a
man in the know
got it yeah so uh uh well you can find
me on pretty much it it's uh you can go
to youtube.com pretty much it to find uh
that's that's a good like starting place
and you can go from there uh and i'm not
personally on social media as much so
i'm just gonna push pretty much it i i
recommend checking out pretty much it uh
and then my movie recommendation
actually is uh it's
i've been thinking about it i don't know
why i've been thinking about it so much
this week but it was when i
was trying to think of what i should
recommend it
it's just the first thing that popped
into my mind so i'm gonna go with my gut
here it's a movie from 2005 called cry
wolf
yeah remember that cry underscore wolf
it was that era
um it is a i guess it'd be considered a
guilty pleasure but um
it is uh i feel like i feel like a lot
of people would appreciate it more with
the rise of games like among us and
stuff you know there's obviously people
play werewolf uh but any of those games
where you're you're you know you're
trying to find who is the who's the
imposter who is the werewolf etc um it's
one of those kind of movies and it uh
2005 uh it's it's got the early 2000s
vibes for sure uh but the the behind the
scenes of it is really interesting it's
a great movie i love that movie and
that's my recommendation and that's like
a bunch of rich kids where they get a
boarding school right yep i got to go
back and i don't know they ever actually
saw that though that's it that's a great
wreck i gotta you check out adventures
in babysitting i'll check out cry done
done awesome hey and now we all have
homework for our next episode uh but
before we get there just remind you all
again wherever you are listening to us
whatever platform whatever provider
please make sure you rate subscribe
follow leave us a review tell your
friends just want to get the word out
because we really do love this podcast
and according to vulture we are fine
that is a little shade but it is
absolutely true we gotta write a fine or
like fine you know no he literally says
in the top line rotten tomatoes is wrong
is fine and you know what i appreciate
any press
fine it's better than bad right yeah
what's wrong with fine again you're
talking to a guy who survived on d-minus
and still got a diploma so
i will alex's review of the mummy what's
wrong with fine the mother
is fine and i will get it up
to because i love you all and and you
did do a good job defending the movie
day i'll get the movie up to like rotten
tomatoes is wrong this movie should be
like 67. all right maybe even 70 i'll
give it a c minus you're still falling
short maybe like 30
for me but that's okay i i'm actually
okay with that i i appreciate your
malleability as you say about your
opinion on movies mark i really think we
need it more in the world oh gosh email
us your recommendations at rt is wrong
and
next week mark what are we doing
this is something that i think a lot of
people are going to give an a or a plus
two and then we had the ending which i'm
sure we'll talk about we are going deep
into the sopranos tony and the whole
gang the whole series hbo's landmark
television
the sopranos
by the week after where we go deep into
jon from cincinnati wow
i mean i woke up this morning and i got
myself a gun
i can't wait to talk about this show
because i had to do a deep dive of it
fairly recently but we'll talk about
next week but i'm very excited to talk
about this because we have the many
saints of newark coming out yeah i was
just gonna ask yeah that's coming out
soon yeah premieres
it's gonna be exciting yeah premieres at
i think new york film festival don't
quote me on that one but definitely one
of those ones that i had to keep out a
lookout anyway join us for that one next
week again i want to thank again mr
brian perez producee lucy our guest
today eric striffler and also my
co-host mr mark ellis as always thank
you all for listening and we'll see
y'all next week
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]